what's up how it's happening everybody
on twitter right now you may have seen
there's this platforming game that's
blowing up everyone is talking about
this game so i had to dust off my old
ipad
find all my old passwords took me 30
minutes
i'm already pissed off but you gotta
play this game it's so difficult
okay fine i'll play i'll play the game
i'll play trap adventure two
never heard of trap adventure one but
apparently
trap adventure two is where it's at
everybody
trap adventure 2.
pretty funky music i can dig this
what does this do okay all right
easy easy
great
[Music]
all right what is wrong with me
that's hilarious never seen that before
[Music]
so i gotta trigger this one
oh my god
[Music]
what do i do then
[Music]
stop
[Music]
okay i get it i gotta land on the edge i
gotta land on the edge
well that went great let's try that
again
all right i see why you wanted me to
play this game now i get it that's
hilarious
hey look at that
okay what do we got this one
this one oh my god i can't jump that far
i can
alright
all right and same whoa holy moly dude
how did i do that no
oh my god i can't do that twice
stop come back here
oh look at that son
i want to scream i want to stick
oh my god
fantastic fantastic
ease easy
tap adventure more like
dumb adventure
[Music]
how do i do that jump it's so sick
whoa where the hell did that come from
look at that son all right all right all
right all right calm down
calm down it's gonna come and then ah
that's right
can you stop can you leave me alone
i don't even know how i do this jump
honestly i just
i've honestly just made it by accident
look at that okay okay okay okay
three things are gonna happen this one
this one and then
i'm just gonna go oh my god oh my god
what's happening
i hate this game whoa look at that okay
okay no uh oh what do i do okay go go go
go go go go go go go go go
what do i do then
what do i do
oh it jumps there
here it is here it is
can you stop moving
great great great just great i would
love to do that again
thank you for asking thank you for
asking i would love to do that again
thank you for asking absolutely we'll
love it
here we go look at that
skill look at that skill son look at
this
yes
you snake you try and get me
what do i go then uh summy messy
no spend all your time
go go go go go go go go go
oh you're kidding me i think i know what
i need to do
look at that look at that look at that
easy easy
[Music]
all right what do i do here i don't even
know what i'm looking at
block ball game
what
[Music]
what do i do
what what
so if i hit the left button it does a
ball
[Music]
oh i'm it's like a reverse
it's like a reverse of that old atari
game
[Music]
oh god oh god oh god okay okay oh great
[Music]
fantastic stop just give me
[Music]
just bounce oh my
lord great
what the [ __ ]
great great great now that's fine that's
fine i want to do it again i want to do
it again it was fun
i was having fun this this bit sucks it
just sucks
okay no
i'm too slow okay i'm fine i'm fine i'm
fine jump off
what happens if i launched the ball
right i launched the ball
and then i jump up then i'm just screwed
oh it keeps going it kills me
okay all right okay fair enough fair
enough
let's keep it on as long as we can and
then we when we don't think we can do it
i bounce
it's gonna come back it's gonna what in
the world is those
what are those am i right okay okay i'm
dead
[Music]
good game good game everyone
at least the music is a plus this is
some of the best
music i've ever heard is mozart level
of god choosing
i can shoot more than one ball fantastic
love the ball game love it the ball
son of a ball
[Music]
what the hell ball
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
just leave me alone please
please oh no go go go go go go
go go i can't beat that what do i do
then
what do i do
you're wasting life spooge go go go
watch out oh it's another one it's
another one fantastic
[Music]
kill me
come on come on come on come on come on
man come on you can do it you can do it
man i believe in you come on come on
come on
oh there's a hole you gotta fight
okay
i
[Music]
i hate you know
[Music]
oh my god it's ridiculous
oh my god i skipped one okay
[Music]
what the hell man now you're just being
mean that's just really mean
where the hell do i go
come on oh my god oh my god it's still
impossible
[Music]
damn it
[Music]
go down you
[Music]
are you kidding me
thank you for watching this video if you
enjoyed leave a like and as always
don't play this game don't play it no
one should play it don't worry about it
okay don't play it do not play it don't
play this game
no one should play this game this game
is why there's evil in the world this
game is why there's hatred in the world
whoever made this game needs to yeah and
thank you for watching this family
friendly video as always
smash that like and subscribe adam god
damn it
[Music]